fallout for PC disks do not contain the
full game data and players will need to
download a portion of the game from
Steam
I'm Kate and this is your GameSpot news
update in a series of Twitter post
Bethesda boss Pete Hines responded to
questions from followers pertaining to
the contents of the PC version fallout 4
on PC comes for the disc and a Steam
authentication key if you don't have a
DVD drive you can just use the key he
explained the game disk has actual
install data though you will still have
to download from Steam the disc doesn't
contain the entire game explaining why
the content has been split in this way
in comparison to console versions Hines
noted that PC requires activation on
Steam for console does not pains also
cited piracy as one of the reasons and
responding to an irate follower
suggesting this would only encourage
piracy so this strategy has been the
norm for Bethesda for numerous years
lots of people bought skyrim Wolfenstein
etc this isn't new we have been doing
this for all our PC games for a while
now
the fallout 4 release date is set for
November 10th across PC Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 Bethesda recently
published the last episode in its
special video series showing how a
little luck can get you far in the
wasteland will you be getting fallout 4
on PC or has this changed your mind let
us know in the comments below or you can
find me on Twitter and how not to draw
I'm Kate and